[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 pueda revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
donald trump es el primer presidente en
la historia de eeuu en enfrentar dos
veces un juicio político en el senado
con miras a su destitución un acto
simbólico porque de igual forma abandona
el cargo de este miércoles
vamos a el salvador que busca atraer más
turistas a través de la educación sobre
su historia específicamente sobre la
guerra civil que vivió el país
centroamericano en los años 80
y la pandemia del coronavirus hizo que
la industria del cine en hollywood se
tomara una pausa pero en colombia en las
telenovelas ya están produciéndose y
nuevamente les mostramos cómo
y vamos a eeuu para nuestra historia
principal en una inédita decisión
bipartidista la cámara de representantes
aprobó iniciar un juicio político en el
senado con miras a la destitución de
donald trump por incitar a la
insurrección el asalto del capitolio por
parte de sus seguidores durante la
ceremonia para certificar los resultados
de las elecciones del 3 de noviembre en
las que yo bailén fue elegido pero más
que sacarlo del poder lo que se busca es
su muerte política los demócratas e
incluso algunos republicanos quieren
evitar que el mandatario saliente pueda
aspirar a llegar a la oficina oval en
cuatro años ya que el mismo trump
reiteró que va a entregar el poder el 20
de enero y el proceso de destitución no
empezará hasta el 19 de enero pues el
senado está en receso y su líder el
republicano mitch mcconnell descartó
convocar lo de emergencia pero ojo ni
siquiera una votación del senado para
destituir a trump de su cargo le
impediría postularse nuevamente en 2024
o después
solo si se declara culpable a trump una
mayoría simple de los senadores podría
impulsar otra votación adicional para
vetarlo de la presidencia en el futuro o
incluso afectar sus finanzas al impedir
que reciba su pensión
esta es la cuarta vez en la historia de
eeuu que los legisladores deciden
iniciar un juicio político contra un
mandatario veamos
andrew johnson en 1868 fue absuelto y
permaneció en el cargo pues los
demócratas se mantuvieron en bloque
apoyando a lo bill clinton en 1998
también fue absuelto y permaneció en el
cargo con el apoyo total de su partido
el demócrata y trump en 2020
primero fue absuelto y permaneció en el
cargo gracias al respaldo republicano y
ahora en 2021 por primera vez 10
representantes republicanos apoyaron
iniciar el proceso
el primer juicio político contra trump
fue por la llamada trama ucraniana es
decir la presunta presión que ejerció
sobre su homólogo ucraniano al amenazar
con retener ayudas económicas si éste no
investigaba los negocios del hijo de joe
biden hunter en ucrania para
perjudicarlo en las elecciones en las
que finalmente obtuvo la victoria
para que el llamado impeachment prospere
se necesita que dos tercios del senado
voten a favor de la destitución es decir
67 senadores de los 100 tendrían que
votar en contra de trump a partir del 19
de enero el senado está compuesto así
los republicanos tienen 50 sillas tras
perder las dos de georgia que ganaron
los demócratas por lo que quedan también
con 50
en ese orden de ideas al menos 17
republicanos tendrían que votar a favor
de la destitución de trump y en caso de
un empate es el vicepresidente como
presidente del senado el encargado de
decidir a partir del 20 de enero
kamala harris
el presidente de donald trump ha
asegurado que el impeachment no es más
que una cacería de brujas y
recientemente ha moderado el tono y
condenó la violencia sin embargo los
demócratas y incluso algunos de los
republicanos creen que los discursos que
ha hecho desde las elecciones de
noviembre hasta ahora han enardecido a
sus seguidores
trump hizo varios llamados a luchar y a
defender con fuerza su supuesta victoria
en las elecciones pero también vamos a
hacerlo pacíficamente en lo que
constituye un mensaje ambiguo revisemos
algunas de sus palabras
estas son las palabras por las que
donald trump es acusado de incitar a la
insurrección
durante un mitin de cara a la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones al senado por
georgia el presidente saliente pidió a
los ciudadanos defender la victoria que
según él le fue robada pese a que la
justicia lo desestimó
los demócratas radicales están tratando
de tomarse las sillas del senado por
georgia para que puedan ejercer poder
absoluto desenfrenado y sin límites
sobre cada aspecto de sus vidas
y los demócratas liberales no tomarán
esta casa blanca
vamos a luchar como demonios se los digo
ahora mismo
en el mismo acto trump presionó el
vicepresidente mike pence a no
certificar el 6 de enero la victoria de
joe biden en las elecciones del 3 de
noviembre precisamente el día de la
certificación trump convocó a sus
seguidores a una manifestación frente al
capitolio
allí les pidió marchar hasta la sede del
congreso para defender su voto hemos
venido a exigir que el congreso haga lo
correcto
y cuente sólo los electores que fueron
asignados de acuerdo a la ley
sé que todos aquí van a marchar pronto
hacia el capitolio para pacífica y
patrióticamente hacer que sus voces sean
escuchadas
y siguieron sus órdenes después del
asalto al capitolio trump divulgó un
vídeo en el que agradecía a sus
seguidores y les pedía irse a casa aún
sin condenar los actos vandálicos
no fue hasta el día siguiente que
rechazó la violencia por primera vez
dijo que entregaría el poder hay un
baile en el 20 de enero desde entonces
ha entregado discursos más moderados en
los que dice que los asaltantes al
capitolio no tienen nada que ver con lo
que él representa
esa violencia va en contra de todo lo
que creo y todo lo que nuestro
movimiento representa ningún seguidor
verdadero mío apoyaría la violencia
política
me respetaría a las fuerzas de la ley
ningún verdadero seguidor mío amenazaría
a otro estadounidense
si usted hizo elogio de eso no está
apoyando nuestro movimiento y está
atacando a nuestro país
sin embargo aún está por verse si con
una semana de distanciamiento puede
borrar más de dos meses de llamados a la
división y denuncias de fraude sin
fundamento
nos vamos a elsalvador este país
centroamericano ha decidido desarrollar
su sector turístico con un giro original
turismo rojo un término que une a las
actividades turísticas con la guerra
civil que destrozó a la nación y dejó
más de 75.000 muertos en los años 80 el
equipo de corresponsales de france 24
preparó el siguiente reportaje
bienvenidos a uno de los destinos que
conforman la ruta del guerrillero detrás
de su máscara en riqueza sonriendo
después de ocho meses sin trabajar
debido a la pandemia finalmente le dio
la bienvenida a su primer grupo de
turistas el turismo rojo es aquel
turismo que se desarrolla en los
diferentes países donde han tenido
conflictos armados en el caso de vietnam
cuba nicaragua ahora el salvador y
tratamos de llevar a las personas a
estos sitios para explicarles acerca de
cómo fue el proceso y en este caso en el
salvador pues en la voz de uno de sus
protagonistas como de don rafa
un rafael es un veterano de guerra pasó
ocho años en estas montañas con un rifle
en su mano nació en una familia pobre y
tomó las armas a los 16 años para
defender a su gente de los operativos
del ejército salvadoreño respaldado por
la silla
de repente ya se podía escuchar que
tenía algo pues de inmediato uno ya
tomaba la posición y comenzaba a
disparar tanto para hacerle bajas al
enemigo como para poder avisar al resto
de los campamentos si había presencia y
que ellos pudieron evacuar desde 1980
hasta 1992
la insurgencia marxista respaldada por
cuba y la entonces unión soviética
combatió al ejército salvadoreño
entrenado por eeuu en estas montañas
varias masacres se llevaron a cabo por
escuadrones de la muerte
es el impacto psicológico de la del
ruido de los motores aparte del
ametrallamiento sino que está dos por
bandera es lo que de hecho sea una causó
bastante temor a los combatientes como
todos los salvadoreños mayores de 30
años emily tiene pocos recuerdos de
infancia de la guerra
qué mejor que poder nutrir de eso las
generaciones que estamos un poco más
jóvenes verdad
aquí algunas señales de la vida en los
campamentos han sido preservadas como
estos tubos de evacuación de 30 metros
de largo construidos para ocultar el
humo de la cocina para que no delatar a
la presencia de las guerrillas
y hay gente que cree que también fue un
mito porque hay gente que no aunque no
lo cuenta puede ser mentiroso esto no
fue así la reintegración social de las
guerrillas fue uno de los principales
obstáculos para la reconstrucción del
país una vez firmado los acuerdos de paz
siguen desmovilizados y sin trabajo en
un país devastado por la guerra que
sigue rechazando los casi 30 años
después
y las películas y los programas de
televisión nos dieron horas y horas de
entretenimiento durante los encierros de
2020 pero la industria tuvo que
detenerse por completo y ahora enfrenta
varios retos en colombia' se están
grabando novelas nuevamente mientras que
en hollywood varios estudios cancelaron
o pospusieron sus planes
de regreso al trabajo en el campo con
premura para el más reciente episodio de
la novela colombiana café los actores
evocan escenas de una vida lejana a la
pandemia global pero el equipo usa
mascarillas y todos se someten a pruebas
regulares de kobe 19 medidas para un
regreso cauteloso en una industria que
fue congelada por el confinamiento de
casi seis meses en colombia
nosotros estábamos
llamaron y nos dijeron que eso
pero el tiempo se volvió un poco solo
pero todo el mundo me dijo 'yo también'
alrededor de 40 telenovelas fueron
canceladas en 2020 en colombia golpeando
a la industria debido a la disminución
de ingresos por publicidad una historia
original de cerca más al norte en
hollywood no hay delincuentes no hay
vaqueros ni siquiera bolas de paja
ruedan por este estudio vacío los sets
fueron cerrados con el gremio de actores
denunciando que la mayoría de los
rodajes no empezarán hasta finales de
enero pues california atraviesa un
repunte de nuevos contagios de kobe 19
una pausa para la industria del cine
estadounidense que ha visto a 150.000
personas perder su trabajo desde inicio
de la pandemia y la televisión puede ser
la próxima víctima dado que muchas
series populares se graban allí puro
cinema la cubrimos ahora la industria
del cine realmente no podemos medir los
efectos en este momento es decir es
menos actual puedes retrasar las
grabaciones sin problemas pero en la
televisión es más difícil
los horarios de grabación son
organizados con mucha antelación y a
veces se graban episodios a medida que
van saliendo al aire así que si hay una
brecha de tres semanas o un mes se hace
problemático en términos de
de hecho la escasez de grandes
lanzamientos ha incentivado el miedo a
que la gente no quiera regresar a los
teatros especialmente con la difícil
competencia que representan los
servicios de streaming por ejemplo el
más reciente lanzamiento de disney soul
se fue directamente a su propia tienda
de pantalla pequeña
live
y un dato al cierre se acuerdan de kiko
el personaje de carlos villagrán para el
chavo del ocho' se registró como
precandidato a la gobernación del estado
mexicano de querétaro estaremos atentos
a ver cómo le irá en su nueva faceta
como político y gracias por acompañarme
en esta emisión de aquí américa
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas cuídense mucho y sigan viendo
france24
[Música]